how  is aretha doing  [Music]  all right just all right  singing is sacred me and you shouldn't  do it just because somebody wants you to  what's most important is that you are  treated with dignity and respect  your specialty you have a talent they  call  genius think about what you're trying to  do to me  how old is she she's 10 but her voice is  going on third at home  how many albums have you had before  i need you to focus and avoid frivolous  distractions  honey find the songs that move you until  you do that  you ain't going nowhere  [Music]  you really like it we love  by this new chick named aretha franklin  [Applause]  franklin you're not about to mess this  up for me  ladies and gentlemen mr rita franklin  look at that this song goes out the  morning to  anyone who's ever felt mistreated  i used to think  you need to take a break i know how to  run my business  have you lost your mind maybe i found it  i believe i have the chills  she's a miracle  [Music]  you